[inaudible]
joining me today is the
founder for act for America,
a New York Times bestselling author and
author of the new book rise in defense
of Judeo Christian values and
freedom. Brigitte. Gabriel,
welcome back to the Rubin report.
Thank you Dave.
I'm delighted to be back with you.
I am delighted that you're here.
First off, before we do anything else,
I was going to wear the exact same shirt.
I love this shirt.
That's a girly girly shirts
that is a girly girly shirt. I
love what's going on here. Okay,
so I had you on about maybe
a year and a half ago or so,
you are the only person in the history
of the Ruben report that you caused the
tear to to formulate in my,
I think you know exactly when it happened.
Yeah, so before I even let you say
anything, we're throwing to the clip.
We only take care of freedom and
preserve it to the next generation.
And I am doing my part as an American,
as a brave American and the home of
the brave to make sure I follow in the
footsteps of our founding fathers.
And do my part as they entrusted me
with that which they have created.
I feel it is my duty to
make sure to preserve it,
to pass it to my children and their
American children and many generations to
come. That's why we fight. And I am
so fortunate that through this fight,
and it is a fight for freedom, for
liberty, for democracy, for security,
for human rights.
I am privileged to meet the most amazing
people that I would never otherwise
meet, like sitting here
with you today. Uh,
and meet friends that have
become lifelong friends,
literally like family to me that I would
never have otherwise met if it wasn't
doing for what I do.
So do I get depressed doing what I do?
Talking about terrorism and
national security, of course I do.
I'm human like everybody.
Sometimes I cry.
Sometimes I'm completely depressed
over things that are happening.
Sometimes I hurt deeply by people who
stabbed me in the back or say bad things
about me or even reading
my Wikipedia profile.
But what keeps me so energized is the
American people and the American spirit
knowing that we are making a difference.
We are growing,
we are changing our country, we
are fighting, we have a purpose.
So when you and I die on our death bed,
we can look back and we can say I made
a difference as we take our last breath
and that's enough for me.
That is how you end an interview. I
mean that's it right there. That was,
that was like your opus right there.
Well because I spoke from the heart
and when you speak from the heart,
your message resonates with people.
And this is exactly why people like you
and me are having such traction with a
lot of people who are saying
we love what you're saying.
It's about time that somebody will
say the things that you are saying,
our message is resonating.
And you know why people want something
genuine and they can tell, you know,
I always tell my children,
the one thing you can never love,
you can never fake glove.
Pico people can tell when you're genuine.
And in a world that we live in
today where everything is fake,
everything is about social media and how
things appear before the camera and and,
and what's in it for me and I'm going to
be your friend because I'm going to get
something out of it.
When people look you and I put our life
on the line because of the conviction
that we have about the truth that we are
speaking and why we are willing to go
to great extent to just fight for
that truth. It resonates with people.
So I couldn't wait to be with you
today. This is great. Why do team,
did you always have this kind of passion?
I mean when you were on last time we told
or you told your your whole life story,
which is absolutely fascinating.
If you want to get me just like a,
a two minute recap and we'll link to it
down below so people can watch the whole
thing if they have it. So you want
to give me a little recap on that,
but I also want to know where your bat,
that smile, that joy, that presence,
where does that come from within
you and did you always have that?
I love life and I am so passionate about
life is because I lived from the age of
10 till the age of 20 waiting
to die every single day.
So every single day in my formula,
two years when I opened my eyes
and I saw sunshine outside,
I didn't know if I'm going
to live to see the sunset.
So living in a bomb shelter,
you know, people ask me
where the special comes from.
My nine 11 happened to me in 1975 when
radical Islam is to blow up my home,
bringing it down, bring me
under the rubble, wounded.
I ended up in a hospital for two and a
half months and later when I came back
home,
my home was no longer the home I left.
I ended up living in this bomb shelter,
eight by 10 room underground,
no electricity, no water,
and very little food.
And that's where I lived for seven
years of my life, robbed of my youth,
barely interacting with people,
barely interacting with people my age.
I lived with my parents who were an
elderly couple in that bomb shelter.
So all this, uh, uh, cooped up passion.
Now I tell people I'm making up
for lost time. So I love life.
I'm so grateful for life.
I'm so grateful for the people I meet,
the places I go. I never thought
I'd live the day beyond 20.
And then I never thought I'd live a day
beyond 30. And here I am, loving life.
I just turned 54 years old. I'm so proud
to make it secret somewhere. Thank you.
Thank you. When, when you have survived,
as long as I have survived,
you brag about I made it to
this day, uh, at this age.
So this is why I love life.
So we're going to link to your,
our original sit down and your whole
story about growing up in Lebanon and all
that so people can watch out
if they haven't seen it. Um,
but not everybody likes
you. And I remember before
I had you on the first time,
uh, you know, when people Google
you, and you even referenced this in,
in that clip we are talking about,
you know, if you check your Wikipedia,
people say all sorts of awful things
about you and all this and I was a little
worried. I was like, ah.
It's like I'm going to have Bridgette
on and I'm going to get hate for it and
all that.
Now I'm really past that part of life.
Now I just want to do what I think is
right and I want to sit down with people
like you and have those conversations.
Um,
but are you shocked at the
kind of pushback you get
for defending the west and
defending Judeo Christian values?
I am no longer shocked. I
was in the beginning I was
very hurt, very disappointed.
I thought my message,
of course the west is going to resonate.
It's going to resonate in the west.
People are going to appreciate why it's
important to fight for freedom of speech.
I was born and raised in Lebanon and a
country where if you stand up against the
status quo and you speak against
the regime, you are killed.
They come take you in the middle of the
night, killed you, you'll disappear.
You don't,
you'll never hear from you again.
I still have friends who
disappeared 30 years ago.
Their parents don't even know
if they are alive or dead.
Journalists in my country of birth and
Lebanon get killed for writing the wrong
thing. So when I came to the West and
when I started speaking in defense of our
freedoms and our values and our way
of life, and the American values of,
of,
you know,
standing up for the truth and speaking
the truth without having to be worried
about somebody killing you,
I could not believe people will,
will come against me like that.
But you know what?
If you don't stand for something,
you know,
yeah,
you have to stand up for what you believe.
Those are the people
that make a difference.
And usually people that make a
difference in this world are not popular.
The most hated people in the look
at Churchill. I mean, you know,
when he was alive, you know, people hated
him. They thought, oh my gosh, you know,
look at him today people,
people call people that have
spoken such words of wisdom.
But people laugh at them when they were
saying them. And so here we are today,
we stand up and we fight. And it
doesn't matter what people say about me,
I do what I believe is right because
I believe we are on a mission to save
Western civilization,
which is under attack right now.
And I'm willing to do my
part to make it happen
is part of the problem of the West now
is that we don't have enough stories like
yours because we've had it pretty good
in the West for the last, you know,
50 some odd years. Certainly in the United
States. We've had it pretty good here.
So we've sort of gotten
fat and lazy on freedom.
We don't know what we're fighting for.
We don't know what are the
generations before us lived through.
You lived through something.
So then you come here and then you see
all these people that are slowly eroding
their freedoms and you're like, Whoa,
I know what this, where this leads
exactly.
My past is America's future.
Unless America wakes up today.
See,
I am the Anne Frank who
lived to tell about it.
Can you imagine if Anne Frank was alive
and the Nazis were spreading worldwide?
Then she just escaped the concentration
camps as you came to the United States
and Nazi-ism started rising
in the United States.
She would be saying the same words
that you when she was alive and with,
in my case, I started speaking after the
attacks on nine 11 on the United States.
I started speaking about the threat of
radical Islam to world peace and our
national security,
but because Americans had it so easy,
they cannot fathom that some
people could hate us so much.
Even though radical Islamic terrorists
hijacked airplanes and use them as a
human missiles, flying them into
skyscrapers with the intention of killing.
Not 3000 but maybe 50,000 that
worked in that building. You know,
if they were like only 15 minutes,
they would have killed tens
of thousands of Americans. Um,
and so this is what I was talking about,
but Americans are such good people.
People in the west who have
never experienced the type
of terrorism that I lived
under cannot relate and think
that somebody could be that bad.
That actually that's the real intention
to kill as many people as possible.
How do you wake people up to that then?
Because it's a really hard,
because not everyone can have the
lived experience that you've had.
You don't have to wake all the people up.
You just have to wake
some of the people up.
You just have to wake up the passionate
I, you know, and my book rise,
I say 2% of the passion,
it's will always rule
the 98% in different,
it doesn't take many to change the world.
2% of the passionate will always
rule the 98% in different.
You just need to get people who
are fired up for your cause.
You need to get people who actually
understand the problem and get the problem
and want to do something
to change the world.
Those are the people that
you need to rally around you.
Those are the people who are gonna
make a difference in this world.
And those are the people that I,
that I tried to communicate with.
And because of that, I was able to
build an organization, act for America.
I'm proud to tell you that we are
now over 1 million members million.
It's incredible. We have chapters
nationwide. We have passed bills,
100 bills on the federal level as well
as the state level to protect America.
So when people tell me,
don't you worry about the names,
I mean people call you names,
you know, they, they, they, they,
they make you look bad.
They are on the list. VSL,
PC calls me and whites up promises.
How do you,
how do you like those white supremacists
lips and that white supremacists skin
and at this white supremacist hair.
Um,
but I tell people when
people slot playbills on you,
it's because they cannot
argue with your facts.
That's why the only thing they
can do is called you names.
They cannot debate you on the facts. And
you know, I tell people all the time,
don't worry about the labels and
don't worry about the haters,
the New York Times and my last book,
they must be stopped.
The book came out in September of 2008
that New York Times interviewed me and
they couldn't find one quote and
my article. So what did they do?
They titled the Article Radical
Islamophobia, not just an Islamophobe.
I am a radical Islamophobe.
Can you imagine if I would've let that
stop me because I was hurt that somebody
didn't like me and they could be a radical
Islamophobe instead of hiding under a
table, you know, trying to
kind of a pat my emotions.
I went there and continue doing exactly
what I do best since 2008 till today,
my organization has helped best 100 bills.
And that's why I tell people don't let
the naysayers and also slap labels on you.
Stop you.
Keep on moving forward.
What do you make of these
leftist organizations,
whether it's SPLC or the
Adl or now in the media,
the New York Times that are actually
empowering the very ideologies that would
love to take away all of their
freedoms. I mean this way, I mean it's,
you've got this Sorta,
you've got the progressive's basically
in bed with the Islamist and to me it's
like they're just sort of willful
idiots or there's probably some other
pejorative.
Okay.
Exactly. You know, and my book cries,
I have a whole chapter titled The
leftest Islam Is Coalition. Yeah.
Because that's exactly what we are
seeing right now coming together.
The enemy of my enemy is my friend.
So we are seeing two people that do
not agree with anything that we say,
do not believe in
America's exceptionalism.
Do not believe that America
should have strong borders.
Do not believe that we know that we need
to have a national identity. We need,
I mean securing our border,
meaning securing and protecting
our national identity.
They do not believe in borders.
They do not believe in language.
They want to bring America down to the,
on part of the rest of the world.
You know, America is equal with Ben as
well. No one is better than anybody.
All societies are created equal.
You are I that even though people
are created equal in the eyes of God,
societies are not created equal.
And so we are seeing right now is leftist
organizations working with the Islam
is, so you've got organizations like the
ACL, Ooh, the southern poverty law center.
Planned parenthood,
uh,
move on that or Gordon with people like
Linda Sarsour who is a devout Islamist,
a proponent of Sharia law,
um,
and working with people like her or
with care coastal and American Islamic
relations. The ACL you is
basically the legal arm of care,
the council on American Islamic Relations.
So do you think they realize
what's going on here?
This is the part that I'm always sort of,
cause I don't like impugning
people's motives. Right.
So it's like do they realize that they're
working with people who once they have
the power will gladly cut them out?
No, they don't. They just
don't. They don't because
people that work for the ACL,
Ooh,
people that work for a different
leftist organizations have good hearts.
They love America,
and they cannot believe that people could
be bad or people couldn't use them for
their end goal.
You know,
when I talk about the Muslim Brotherhood
project and you and I have talked about
the Muslim Brotherhood project
in our previous interview,
people need to go watch that interview
with me. Everybody watching us right now,
they need to go back and watch
that previous interview. Um,
the Muslim Brotherhood wrote a plan at
100 year plan radical Islam to infiltrate
and dominate the West and establish
an Islamic government on earth.
What makes the plan so unique,
especially the plan for the United States,
for the destruction of America?
The last page of the plan for America,
let's 29 front Islamic organizations
set up in the United States with the
specific purpose of sabotaging
America and destroying it from within.
Many of these organizations
that I mentioned, Isna,
Islamic Society of North America,
uh,
the MSA Muslim students association care,
which started as I AAP Islamic Association
for Palestine later became care
because they wanted to create another
name because the FBI was on their tail
knowing that they are a Hamas
front in the United States.
Those are the names mentioned.
So what we're seeing right now is
people like the Hclu move on that or the
southern poverty law center are basically
used as the useful idiots at the hands
of what Islam is with an agenda.
So while I am very upset at how the Adl
or the SPLC or the ACL EU is taking the
side of Islam,
is that against people like me?
I'm not sure what they say about you,
but I know they hate my guts. I, yeah.
And so I see that and it's,
it's sad to realize that their good
intentions are being used to do something
bad at the end, but they don't
realize it at this point. Meanwhile,
they're working with the Islam is
against people like me who basically are
trying to warn against the same people
who are going to destroy them at the end.
And that's why I framed it
the question that way cause I don't
like attacking people's motives.
And I believe that if we were to sit down
with all of the people at the ACL you,
that the vast majority of them are,
are totally doing all of these things
for what they believe to be the the right
reason,
the right reason.
Yet they've been just sort of tricked
into having some really unholy alliance.
Look, the southern poverty law
center, uh, the same thing.
They started as a good organization
fighting the Klu Klux Klan doing something
good that was a result
that they raised money,
they fought the Klu
Klux Klan and look the,
the Klu Klux Klan deserves to be in a
whole because we in America will never
ever tolerate such true hatred.
But for them right now to slap the label
hate on anybody who speaks the truth or
do not agree with their point of view.
They don't know what my heart is. I see.
I never judge anybody's heart. I
am the same way. You never know.
People would ask me about,
uh, Barack Obama. Do you
think he's a Muslim? You know,
I cannot judge anybody's heart.
I don't know who he prays for.
I didn't know what's between
him and he's God, he's God.
That's what he does in the
privacy of his own home.
And I will never judge where he stands.
And a lot of people on the right,
they didn't even like me saying
those words. But that's the truth.
I will never judge what's in somebody's
heart or what's in somebody's mind.
I judged them by their actions. So
now when people slap labels on me, oh,
she's a hater.
You don't even know me.
You have never even sat
down with me and talked me.
How can you start the label and emotional
label on somebody that you don't even
know
if you're a hater? You're seriously
much better actress than hater.
Because you got me for lady
I, I'm telling you. I mean, you know,
it is so sad to see that coming from them
and they're not listening to whatever
explanation or even when we reach out
to them, they don't want to talk to us.
They don't want to hear our side of the,
of the view is like they judged
us in absentia and that is it.
You know, the, speaking of
judging and [inaudible],
they are no better than the
terrorist in Lebanon. You know,
I went to Israel this year and
a visit with my parents' grave.
I didn't know if you know my parents, I
bird with Oskar Schindler and Mount Zion.
Yeah.
And so this was the first time.
Tell people how you ended up in
Israel after leaving Lebanon.
Well, I left Lebanon. I
ended up moving to Israel,
becoming a news anchor for world
news and working in Jerusalem.
And when my parents died,
I wanted to make sure that I buried them
in Israel because I wanted to make sure
that my children yet unborn will
always know where my loyalty lies.
And because I'm a firm believer that
actions speak louder than words.
So I wanted to make sure I honor my
parents because I adore my parents said,
this is a very sensitive subject
with me. Uh, I'm an only child.
I worship my parents.
I live every single day of my life doing
everything I do to honor them and their
legacy. And you know, speaking of hatred,
some former employer did me
wrong when I was 22 years old.
And I remember sitting on my father's
lap and he's wheelchair hugging him.
I was crying and I said,
Oh Daddy, I just hate them.
I get believe they did this to us. And
my father said to me, he said, I never,
ever want to hear that word coming out of
your mouth. I never raised you to hate.
And if for nothing else,
because of the way I adore
my father at that day,
at 22 years old,
I vowed I will never hate somebody.
My father died like two weeks later.
I will never,
ever allow hate to enter my heart
towards my enemies, towards anybody.
I don't hate anybody. So when my
parents died, I buried them in, in,
in Jerusalem. They are buried
with Oscar Schindler, Mount Zion.
We're actually later he was
brought in and buried next to them.
So this year I went back
to Lebanon to Israel.
And because I cannot go to
Lebanon, Hezbollah wants
me dead. So I go to Israel,
I visit Israel,
I meet with the IDF.
I actually was the first Lebanese person
to ever make it to the rooftop of the
idea of headquarters in Tel Aviv.
And I recorded videos with
the spokesperson of the IDF
and with the top generals.
We recorded videos to be
broadcast to the United Nations,
to the international community video
to be broadcast to Lebanon about how,
why we need to work together towards
peace, why we need to love each other.
Put Peyto side,
forget what you're told about the Jews.
Israel doesn't want anything
but peace with its neighbors.
Let's work together on peace.
And for that Hezbollah air
that on Lebanese television,
they charged me with treason.
Now I am wanted that in Lebanon and
sentenced to death by hanging and obsess
[inaudible].
So here we have a group of terrorists
and my home country of Lebanon who judged
me and who I am and I deserve to be good
sentence to death by hanging because
they did not agree with me preaching a
message of love about being friends with
the Jews. So here we have
them calling me haters. Yeah.
And yet I have the loftiest in America,
the southern poverty law center and
these people calling me haters simply
because I'm mourning about
the Islamic terrorist threat.
All right, well you've got too much
good in you to focus on the haters.
But I do have one other question about
the haters and then we're going to just
put it behind us,
which is when Majid Nawaz
sued the southern poverty
law center and now he's been
removed from their anti
Muslim extremist list.
And you were on there still as far as
I know. Uh, I is I on still on there
actually that let, yeah, I honest to
La over the enemy and I on of course.
Are you kidding? Um, no.
Linda Sarsour once your,
once my private parts removed. Yeah.
Miss Women's feminist movement. You know,
um, but that the world is turned upside
down so we are still on that list,
um,
sit or a lawsuit or anything because
I'm not generally for lawsuits in these
cases.
But magic proved that if they've really
wronged you and you can get the backing
to get the lawyers to do it,
that ultimately justice does prevail.
We talk to our attorneys to sue them and
it's going to cost a lot of money and
they can drag it for
years and years and years,
I've gotten onto at 90 attorneys on
staff while we have to depend on the
generosity of attorneys to do with pro
bono. Yeah. They get drag it forever.
Plus because I'm a public person and the
head of an organization that will get
us into discovery,
which means they not
only can't subpoena me,
which I don't say anything bad,
I'm not worried,
but they can go after my chapters and
any communications our chapters have done
with their friends. Now our
chapters are completely independent.
They're members are
completely independent. I
don't even know who they are.
So if somebody sent a personal email to
a third party mentioning any word about
hate, which we are completely
not responsible for because
they don't speak about
headquarters, they can say, see we
told you they've got people that Tate.
And so because I do not know three,
four levels down.
See now she doesn't have
a national organization.
Definitely not with chapters
and members the way we do.
So he's only responsible for what t says.
I can fight and defend what I say,
but I cannot fight and defend what
people die. I don't even know. Look,
the SPLC went after us and they said,
oh, we've got white supremacists.
You know who show up to our rallies
we haven't drawn is on the side street
corner. Yeah. Anybody can stand on
the side street corner. You know,
you cannot say that these members belong
to my organization. Yeah, but they do.
And that's the tactic
of the left right now.
All right,
let's focus on
the book.
So the,
the subtitle is in defense of
Judeo Christian values and freedom.
So just most simply, if someone said to
you, what our Judeo Christian values,
what are they? What are,
where do the most fundamental,
Judeo Christian values
that we need? No. Well,
do they have Christian values are
the bedrock of Western civilization.
They are the foundation of
what we have today in America.
And this is not a religious
book at all. Yeah, you read it,
you endorsed it. Yeah. It's not a
religious book. A little bit more there.
You got a little blurb in there.
One of the most fundamental freedoms.
I'll give you a perfect example.
Freedom of speech.
People don't realize where that freedom
comes from. You know, and Israel,
the Hasidic Jews, they debate
the Bible. They 24 hours a day.
That's all they do. They debate the
Bible. And what does that come from?
The Bible says, come let's reason
together means let's debate ideas.
I may not like your idea.
You may not like mine and we can have
five other people who might look at the
same verse completely differently.
But the reason why we debate ideas is
because we can learn from each other and
better understand what statements mean.
Where'd the author who wrote
that statement meant by it?
We all know that God didn't write
the Bible. People wrote the Bible.
So part of our fundamental way of
thinking, the freedom of speech,
the ability to come together and debate
ideas and passionately debated these
ideas yet agree to respectfully
disagree and walk away.
People don't realize that comes
from the foundation of today.
A Christian Foundation.
You know,
even people who are not religious
understand that. So uniquely Western,
you know, they don't do that. And, and,
and, and the Islamic world for example,
you don't debate ideas.
Why? Because in the Qur'an,
the Qur'an was written, it's the
word of God. It's not debatable.
It's not negotiable. You can not
look back. You can add change versus,
and you don't even talk about it.
You can even question it very
different than the way we are.
So when I write in the book about, and
I actually, I have a chapter titled, uh,
the death of free speech where I talk
about how we are losing our ability to
speak the truth because then you're
labeled your biggest people are afraid.
Am I going to be, you know,
black man? Am I going to be card?
Am I gonna lose my job? Um, and so it's,
we're silencing ourselves and
that's why I titled the Book Rise,
Rise in defense of today are Christian
values and freedom because we're losing
those freedoms, those American
values before our very eyes.
Are you watching this chip away more in
Europe than in the United States right
now for all our problems around this,
and I agree at the bigger problem right
now is that we're silencing ourselves
rather than the government
coming to silence us.
Although that could potentially be a
problem in the future, I don't sense.
It's a huge problem right now.
Europe has a whole other set
of problems around free speech.
Do you think that they're more suited
to lose faster because they don't have a
first amendment the way we do?
Oh yeah,
there are far
more advanced than losing their
rights and their freedoms than we are.
And they did it by self censorship.
You know, I landed in London,
I was speaking in London in 2007,
so I land in London.
I'm a standing there waiting
for my luggage with the um, uh,
pilot and the hostesses,
uh,
we were in a private section and they
said, oh, what are you doing here?
And I said, Oh, I'm just
here for like three days.
I'm giving a speech in parliament.
I was speaking to the, uh,
British parliament and they said, oh,
what are you going to be talking about?
And I said, the threat of radical Islam
to world peace and national security. Oh.
And all of a sudden silence for 30
seconds. You could hear a pin drop.
They didn't know how to react or what to
say. They were so afraid to react less.
Somebody hears something.
The taxi driver,
my driver picked me up to drive me to
my hotel and we were talking in the car
and I told them, you asked me
again, what are you doing here?
And I said the same thing. He
said, Bridgette, in 10 years,
I believe we're going to have blood
on the streets of London by radical
Islamists.
We are at war and it
didn't even take 10 years.
Within five years,
we already started seeing stabbing on the
streets of London and stuff like that.
So in Europe they are afraid to talk
about it and they do not have the freedom
of speech that we have.
And that's why it is so important to
defend the freedom of speech that we have.
And God bless them, our founding
fathers would, their wisdom,
they knew exactly what they
were doing. I mean, look,
remember they came from Europe.
So when they wrote us what they gave us
the constitution and our bill of rights
and all of that stuff,
they knew exactly why they put
some of these amendments are there.
So all right, so let's just put a Europe
aside. Since we're in the United States,
they're going to have to deal with
that. We'll deal with it here. Um, okay,
we can get people to rise.
But what else do we have to do to have
a discussion about this that's going to
stop the people that are going
to use all of those labels.
So I know even in the book
you make a point of saying,
of course this is not all Muslims
and don't be bigoted towards Muslim.
People were talking about an ideology.
A lot of people have been doing
that for the last couple of years.
Tried to separate people from ideas and
all that and still get all the labels
thrown at them.
What are some of the other techniques we
can use to talk about these things and
not be crushed by,
by all the Labor?
Don't waste your breath because there
is nothing you can say at this point.
No matter what you say, the
enemy, the SPLC, the Adl,
move on that or organizing for action.
All the progressive organizations,
they're not willing to listen to you.
They don't want to listen to you. Look,
we organized march against sharia,
March for human rights last year,
a year and a half ago.
Uh,
and we had rallies in 29 cities in 21
states and we timed it with the pulse
nightclub bombing and Florida
because it was June 10th,
we wanted to shine a light about the
hatred of this ideology against gays,
what they do to gays.
I mean,
look at the pulse nightclub bombing that
the people that organize our rallies in
New York. It was organized
in, headed by two gay guys.
The rally in Atlanta was
headed by a Muslim man.
Do we had an imam mom speaking in Seattle.
We had Miriam Ibrahim this.
So then he survivors speak up our rally
in Virginia Beach as well as an Iranian
Muslim leader of the Iranian movement,
you know,
to to to two away from the molars.
Yeah.
Did you think any of the
media covered any of that?
All they did is show up on the street
corners. I know. Hey, it's say no to hate.
Say not the, hey, they didn't even bother.
Yeah. Understand what we were doing.
So don't waste your breath right now.
People tell me,
why are you speaking to the choir,
Bridget?
We need to talk to other
people at this time.
You need to mobilize the choir because
when you need your house cleaned,
it is the choir that shows up.
It is the choir that brings you food.
When you're sick,
it is the choir that maps the church
or the temple when it needs cleaning.
It's the choir that brings the flowers
and that's all that matters to keep your
house up and keep it protected
and that's why right now,
don't waste your breath on the labels.
Make sure you fight.
Make sure you lobby
your elected officials.
Make sure you understand
the power of the gavel,
why it is important to call your
elected officials. You know in my book,
what makes this book so unique
is that the end of every chapter,
I have a section titled Dries Up
and act where I give people ideas.
So I want to do all that at the end.
I want all,
I want all of your absolute advice
on this, but what are you hit on?
Something that I think is
really interesting there.
How there's a connection to all of this
and the way the media reports. Yeah,
you're right. That when they cover
your events or when they cover,
a lot of the people that I'm friends
with that I have on the show,
whatever they say,
it's like they only focus on the haters.
They only focus on that.
The one little outsider that's,
that's doing something that's
bad and not on all the good. How,
how do you think this happened to the
media or is there a way that it can be
fixed or does it need to
burn to the ground or what?
Because the progressive media
is not interested in dialogue.
They are interested in winning.
See,
we on the conservative side,
you know, and it's such a shame.
I never thought of myself
as opposed to serve. I mean,
I don't know if I told I voted for
Al Gore, I was a proud democrat.
I'm a nine 11, you know, conservative
as they call us conservative. Uh,
but this is where we are
and our nation right now,
they consider people like you conservative
because you speak about, you know,
important issues that are now known as,
oh,
that's what the conservatives
talk about. Yeah. You know,
so what we are seeing right now is
the media is interested in winning.
While we are interested in having good
dialogue, how can we get through to them?
How can we speak with them,
you know,
and find the bridge where we
can talk to them about that.
They're not interested in talking to us.
They're interesting in
silencing our voices.
And the sooner we know that the better
we are in fighting our battle and
learning how to win our battle. And
you add to that, funders like sorrows,
you know,
and my book,
I have a whole section about sorrows and
him funding the media source right now
has spent
do an anti Semite. If you talk
about Soros, that's their new meme.
I didn't even know he was
Jewish until about a year ago.
[inaudible] he does is
usually against Israel.
Exactly. The height of stupidity.
Yeah. Uh, I mean, you know,
you would think, keep sounds on talks like
an antisemite much more than me. Right?
Remember, he is the one who works with the
doctors, with the Nazis on, on, on, um,
and actually had a smile
when people ask them,
how did you feel about going in and
working with the Nazis against your own
people? He said, well, you
know, somebody had to do it.
So I know I got say any problem with it,
you know? Yeah. You're not making that up,
by the way. No, no. I mean,
I watched these interview because I was
very interested on what makes this man
the way he is. I studied my enemies. Uh,
I spend a lot of hours actually
studying my enemies, uh,
to understand how they think,
why, why do they behave, you know,
trying to pick up on cues.
So you look at somebody like George Soros,
who is interested in transforming
America into his vision of how the world
should be, and he has the billions
and he's willing to spend that.
43 billion has already
been spent on the media,
on Soros funded media
entities from, uh, since 2002.
And so when you look today at SARS,
has tentacles extend to a 33
media outlets including ABC, NBC,
CBS, MSNBC, the Washington
Post, the Associated Press,
which I detail in my book. Uh, even
though the, to give you an example,
which I talked in the book,
uh,
Columbia School of journalism gave them
$600,000 to their journalism school
because he wanted to impact the reporting
on how reporters report on the media
issues in the future. So nobody
was paying attention to this stuff.
But this is exactly how we ended up with
reporters who are no longer reporters.
They are activists with
a national platform media
platform who get on television
every night and basically spew the same
talking political points approved by
sorrows. And they all say the same
thing, whether it's the Huffington Post,
the New York Times, the Associated
Press, Reuters, MSNBC, CNBC,
ABC, the same buzzword.
And it's all coordinated.
How concerned are you that on the social
media front where people like you who
have been able to make gains,
you know,
I'll see every now and
again you'll talk about, oh,
I just suddenly lost 5,000 followers
on Twitter or something like that,
that we're fighting a
losing battle on that front.
Ultimately because these companies a,
I think there are a lot of political
connections and who knows what's going on
behind the scenes, but B,
they've basically embraced the,
the leftist ideology and they're not
really around to make sure that Bridgette
Gabriel's voice can be heard.
Well, we lose followers by the tens
of thousands, tens of thousands. Uh,
and we are seeing that happen
especially now at a dramatic pace. Uh,
but you continue on doing
what you are doing it,
there's nothing you can do to change
it. Uh, you just continue pushing.
We are working with members of Congress
to make sure that there's fairness and
reporting and that the government will
intervene to make sure that we don't have
a monopoly. Look, they did
the same thing with Microsoft.
Remember Microsoft had a
monopoly. The government had
to intervene. And they said,
no, you cannot stop anybody else
who wants to develop computers.
Apple didn't have a chance
of, the government didn't
intervene with Microsoft.
So we know that there is precedent,
but here's the secrets to success.
My Libertarian brain,
all the bells go off on that stuff though
because I don't want the government to
do it.
It's like for me it's like be last resort.
Even though I know that this is obviously
a very personal issue to me as someone
that puts this up on
youtube and the rest of it,
we want that fairness.
We're not telling them silence anybody,
but we are saying to them, allow
people to speak their mind. You know,
if I own a media platform and I do not
agree with you at all in what you say,
as an American,
I will bite my tongue and grit my
teeth and listen to what I absolutely
passionately opposed. I'm not
saying you, but anybody you know.
You could be saying,
you know what, whoever,
but I will fight for
your right to do with,
I will not silence you because
it is an American to silence you.
So as Americans,
we owe it to each other at least
to defend these rights so we can,
so we can pass them out to our future
generations. You never really own freedom,
David. We only preserve it
for the future generation.
And I said that statement with you before,
and I actually have it going
all throughout my book.
These are the rights that our
founding fathers gave everything,
and most of them died broke to give
us these rights that we have today.
The least we can do is preserve
it for the next generation.
That's all we're asking for.
But you know the secret to success,
regardless of how much the,
the social media puts you on Facebook
jail or Twitter bands, your shadow banned,
et Cetera, tenacity, tenacity,
tenacity. You keep on pushing,
you keep on pushing. You keep on pushing
and you never, ever, ever give up.
That is the secret to success.